il fut un temps que ça n'allait pas très
fort pour le paris saint-germain
démissions font du grand changement
quand ça va plus au milieu des années
2000 le psg est un club malade peut pas
continuer comme ça sinon on va tout
droit à l'échec mauvais résultats des
supporters des prix mais plutôt change
le 31 mai 2011 nous étions les premiers
à vous donner l'information dès ce midi
le psg est vendu à des investisseurs du
qatar le psg rachetée à 70% par un fonds
d'investissement qatari le budget
explose passant de 80 à 150 millions
d'euros et le premier coup de folie
n'attend pas 2011 une star et recruter
l'argentin javier pastore
montant 42 millions d'euros un record
pour le championnat français à l'époque
pour la ligue 1 pour le football
français pour les spectateurs qui ont
dans les stades c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle de voir des grands joueurs qui
risquent d'arriver au paris saint
germain le psg veut développer sa marque
à l'international
c'est le début du foot business pour le
club 2012 d'autres grands noms arrivent
le la times bregovic thiago silva pour
paris c'est une stratégie marketing car
attirer de tels joueurs c'est s'assurer
de gagner encore plus d'argent retour
sur investissement va être extrêmement
rapide car vous allez avoir des ventes
de maillots tout ce qui est produits
dérivés vous allez avoir une
augmentation des abonnements et vous
allez avoir en plus des droits
télévision qui vont sûrement être
augmenté et ce n'est qu'un début 2013 le
psg frappe fort sur le marché des
transferts énorme coup médiatique pour
paris david beckham 37 ans signe
gratuitement mais peu importe l'âge
l'anglais bien plus qu'un joueur de foot
c'est aussi une vitrine pour le club et
ça c'est tout bénef pour le psg avec
david beckham le paris saint germain
parle non seulement au marché français
au marché européen mais également aux
450 millions de chinois qui consomment
du football aujourd'hui quatre ans plus
tard en 2017 le club de la capitale va
encore plus loin avec l'arrivée de
neymar la star brésilienne
très contents de l'accueillir benvenuto
me marre montant de l'opération
accrochez vous bien 222 millions d'euros
encore aujourd'hui c'est le plus gros
transfert de l'histoire du foot mondial
mais pour nasser al-khelaifi le
président du psg qu'importe les millions
dépensés ce qui compte ce sont les
retombées économiques ni mort si l'on
considère neymar quand les marais - avec
le paris saint-germain je suis sûr que
nous gagnerons plus d'argent que nous en
avons dépensé
neymar aurait rapporté plus de 400
millions d'euros au psg dès sa première
saison selon un rapport révélé par le
quotidien espagnol marca en 2021 autre
chiffre d'importance depuis l'arrivée
des qataris en 2011 en dix ans paris a
dépensé près d'1 4 milliard d'euros en
transferts sur les réseaux sociaux il
est passé de 500 milles à plus de 100
millions d'abonnés le psg fait partie
des clubs les plus riches au monde mais
la ligue des champions se fait toujours
attendre
[Musique]
oh